the Paleo do isn't about historical
reenactment it's about taking the
sensible principles of eating and saying
well this makes sense I started out
doing a popup restaurant with my concept
and now we've opened London's first
paleo
restaurant so the whole purpose of the
paleo diet is to go back to real food
vegetable balls meat eating all the
parts of an
animal I did chemistry at University and
the things about chemistry that I found
Most Fascinating were always the stuff
to do with how the body works or how
food worked so I started to study
part-time at the weekends while I
finished my degree doing my nutrition
diploma there was part of me still that
felt that something was missing and for
me it
def we ran the kickstarter campaign P to
get an extra 30 grand cuz we really
wanted to be inside Zone one and that
pretty much was the premium difference
um to get into Zone one um we had some
Angel Investors and some investment from
friends and family there were plenty of
restaurants that were much cheaper but
because we're quite unique in what we do
we wanted to be really accessible we
were very lucky Kickstarter actually
attracted more investment than we needed
um we we've actually we still got a a
list of people willing to invest when we
want to
expand Christmas dinner is probably one
of the easiest meals to make Paleo
because you've got a big chunk of meat
which is about as paleo as it comes swap
your bread based stuffing for a chestnut
based stuffing your potatoes some paleo
people eat white potatoes but if they
don't and sweet potatoes cook them in
dark fat amazing um paleo or paleo
versions of dessert are quite easy if
they're fruit-based so Christmas pudding
is quite an easy one to do you replace
the flour with ground almonds or you can
make you can even make Paleo ice cream
by by chili mut Custard in an ice cream
chain and sweetening it with a bit of
maple
syrup